this morning a former US Marine received
a 16 year prison sentence in Moscow for
alleged espionage Paul Whelan says he's
not a spy and the russians set him up to
be arrested back in 2018 Elizabeth
Palmer is tracking the case that the US
ambassador to Russia calls a mockery of
Justice Paul Whelan heard the verdict
but with no interpreter was the last
person in the court to understand it
he's facing 16 years hard labor on top
of the year and a half he spent in
Moscow's LeFort ago jail Whelan had
visited Russia several times then in
December 2018 staying in the Metropole
Hotel to attend a wedding agents from
Russia's security services burst into
his room and arrested him for spying
today's verdict is not a surprise but
the US ambassador to Moscow John
Sullivan says it is an outrage with
political consequences
Wieland's trial was held in secret
except for the occasional photo op the
case against him he says was a setup a
security officer he thought was a friend
had planted secret information on him to
get a promotion Wieland's brother david
says the family is hoping that
diplomatic negotiations can now start to
get home what do you want to see next
from the American government now we
expect the administration the Trump
administration to take the next step
there should no longer be any diplomatic
hurdles to have those discussions with
the Russian government basically the
family believes that the Russians will
be willing to exchange Paul for
something the question is what it could
be a couple of very expensive properties
the US government confiscated from the
Russians in the u.s. in the wake of the
election meddling scandal or it could be
a Russian or Russians in American jail
scale all right Elizabeth Palmer
reporting from London thank you